bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
le magazine d'information européenne a
réalisé au coeur du parlement européen
nous sommes cette semaine à strasbourg
et nous allons prendre ce sera le
reportage de cette émission la route des
balkans principal chemin vers l'europe
où plus d'un million de réfugiés depuis
2014 problème les frontières sont
fermées en hongrie slovénie et en serbie
forçant des centaines de migrants à
rester dans ces camps improvisés comme
ici à tabac noche en macédoine vous
verrez ce reportage tout à l'heure mais
d'abord notre débat de la semaine
faut-il encore plus de transparence
bancaire et fiscale en europe
le temps du secret est il révolu
questions à la une après les révélations
des panamas papers on en parlera avec
une d'éviter que vous découvrirez juste
après ce petit résumé en images un
dirigeant européen touché par le
scandale des bana ma papers
david cameron l'a reconnu il a bien
perçu des revenus du fonds
investissements au genre maussac fonséca
le premier ministre britannique a joué
cartes sur table il a publié tous ses
revenus depuis 2009 et a même fait son
mea culpa devant les caméras je sais que
j'aurais dû mieux gérer cette affaire
je sais qu'il y a des leçons à en tirer
je serai bon souvenir la déferlante
panama papers concerne aussi des banques
comme la société générale et des
entreprises européennes accusées de
détenir des comptes offshore non
déclarés une affaire qui en rappelle une
autre novembre 2014
le scandale luc slicks ébranle le
continent une enquête internationale de
journalistes révèlent l'existence de
centaines d'accords fiscaux très
avantageux conclut avec le fisc
luxembourgeois pour le compte de
sociétés multinationales comme apple ou
amazon
un paradis fiscal au coeur même de
l'union européenne qui ternit le début
de mandat de jean claude juncker ancien
premier ministre du luxembourg devenu
président
la commission européenne la commission
fera son travail
moi je m'abstiendrai d'intervenir dans
ce dossier
j'ai une idée sur le sujet mais je là
que je la garderai pour moi
hasard du calendrier ce mercredi
bruxelles a présenté son plan pour
lutter contre l'opacité des
multinationales c'est l'une des
priorités de la commission européenne ou
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale des
grandes entreprises qui sont présentes
en europe et je peux dire qu on a
progressé dans la transparence
la directive instaure une obligation
pour les entreprises ayant une filiale
dans l'union et un chiffre d'affaires
supérieur à 750 millions d'euros
elles devront publier leurs bénéfices et
les impôts qu'elles payent pays par pays
l'exécutif européen part en croisade
contre l'évasion fiscale une liste noire
européenne des paradis fiscaux sera
publié le temps du secret c'est fini
parole du commissaire européen pierre
moscovici
l'union sera la première zone du monde à
franchir le pas de la transparence
totale et nous accueillons sur ce
plateau sylvie goulard bonjour bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne membre de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe et spécialiste de
ces questions on voit que deux
commissaires sont à la manoeuvre pierre
moscovici et son collègue britannique
john atta mills pour tenter d'en finir
avec tous ces chiffres cachent et de
l'évasion fiscale pierre moscovici
promet une transparence totale
on a du mal à y croire est ce que c'est
un rêve parce que ça peut devenir
réalité
d'abord une petite remarque par rapport
à votre reportage ce n'est pas un
problème spécifiquement européen
ce que la sphère panaméen démontre c'est
que nous sommes confrontés à des
phénomènes qui touche toute la planète
et que des individus se cachant derrière
des sociétés écrans installés dans des
pays parfois extrêmement petit peuvent
priver d état de recettes fiscales et
donc une certaine manière voler les
contribuables je comprends tout à fait
l'émotion des populations c'est une
forme de dérobade citoyennes sont des
gens qui profitent des installations des
services publics mais ne contribue pas
aux charges
mais à l inverse il faut se méfier un
petit peu des solutions trop hâtives
je suis très frappé de voir qu'en
général on reproche toujours à l'europe
à la fois d'en faire pas assez et
lettres trou naïve je crois que la vraie
bataille c'est que l'europe soit en
pointe pour qu'au niveau global signé
plus de paradis fiscaux si nous
pratiquons une transparence qui est
seulement unilatérale mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer les entreprises iront
ailleurs puisque au contraire on va les
inciter à ne pas aller à l'endroit qui
est le plus transparent voilà je voulais
faire cette petite remarque donc vous
puisque l'europe s'y prend bien des deux
sets cette directive sans discuter avec
les états unis effectivement pas ce que
vous dites que 100 sans solution à
l'échelle du monde
on peut pas régler lors des discussions
existent à le céder notamment je crois
que don qui est un organisme
international qui a son siège à paris
qui comporte la plupart des puissances
occidentales et donc la galice
américains les canadiens les mêmes les
japonais les australiens et c'est donc
c'est un cadre qui a contribué à faire
faire décorer et effectivement c'est le
niveau où l'europe doit agir de manière
unie on a voté hier à mon rapport intime
rapport d'initiative sur la place de
l'europe dans les enceintes financière
monétaire économique fiscale globale
alors qu'elle est elle cette place
justement là pour l'instant
objectivement on n'a pas pris le
problème au sérieux
jusqu'à présent les états ont choisi est
là la responsabilité dans les états de
maintenir un jeu de concurrence entre
eux c'est à dire qu'on joue les états
les uns contre les autres c'est ce
qu'avait montré la sphère le xixe
quand les luxembourgeois attire les
revenus d'entreprise par exemple qui
font des hamburgers en france l'activité
chez nous et par le biais de l'existence
du luxembourg ont des robes la matière
fiscale donc il ya une première étape
qui est d'éviter entre nous une
concurrence abusive
la deuxième étape c'est d'aller ensemble
plaider au niveau global en mettant
toute la force de l'union tout la taille
de son marché dans la balance et le
faire je dirais en faisant des gestes de
transparence mais en les conditionnant
aussi à la transparence des autres je ne
suis pas pour le déshabillage
unilatérale des entreprises européennes
parce que dans ces cas là encore une
fois nous manquerions l'objectif et cela
suppose aussi que les états membres
jouent
je entre ce qui n'est pas forcément
toujours le cas avec c'est exactement le
problème de notre temps si vous prenez
la question des réfugiés
si vous prenez la question de la zone
euro si vous prenez la question de
panama vous avez le choix
moi je le pose aux téléspectateurs est
ce que l'on voulait continuer à
valoriser une souveraineté qui non
seulement n'existent plus parce que les
flux son nom du aurait en plus se
retourne contre nous puisque si chacun
revendique sa souveraineté
les autres ont leur souveraineté panama
les îles vierges britanniques
même les états unis à certains égards
dont un état comme le delaware c'est
rosie de paradis fiscal où est ce que
nous passons à des rapports européenne
d'une part et globaux plus coopératifs
dans lesquels on dépasse ce stade
gemma souveraineté j'ai mon veto jeu
baisse mais tu as fiscales et dans le
fond je tends bête parce qu'en fait
c'est ça la réponse aux autres et je
trouve que le débat en france qui fait
en deux parts aux souverainistes qui les
laisse raconter n'importe quoi sur les
vertus de la souveraineté mériterait
d'être un peu plus approfondie sur cette
question des packs de maps earth et de
ce qu'elle révèle
est ce que pour vous le temps du secret
est révolu il faut vraiment prendre des
mesures fortes alors à l'échelle des
états membres et aussi à l'échelle du
monde pour pour en finir avec ces
secrets la voix il faut garder une mare
de secret là tu n'y a aucun doute sur je
dirais le secret permet soit à des
personnes qui veulent éviter la loi de
leur pays et leur ont dit pour de bonnes
raisons mais même dépouiller son ex
épouse dans un divorce ou dépouiller ses
enfants enfin peu importe c'est pas très
glorieux mais vous avez surtout derrière
les panneaux même les peurs tout le
crime organisé vous avez le blanchiment
de l'argent de la drogue le blanchiment
la traite des femmes dans la
prostitution des enfants dans la
pédophilie et c'est donc la transparence
oui après il faut voir quelles sont les
modalités encore une fois je dis bien
les plus efficaces c'est à dire que par
exemple pour des entreprises mettre tout
sur la place publique présente des
avantages peut présenter des
inconvénients en termes de concurrence
est ce que nous voulons que nos
entreprises pour que les emplois chez
nous pas tease
fait que nous donnons à leurs
concurrents qui ne sont pas astreints
aux mêmes règles encore une fois à un
désavantage donc par exemple une bonne
solution à mon avis c'est déjà
d'encourager énormément les échanges
entre administrations fiscales
c'est-à-dire transparence des
entreprises vis-à-vis des
administrations fiscales qui
transmettent aux administrations qui ont
donc cette directive
ces directives européennes n'est pas
forcément là elle voit les leçons des
difficultés vous avez une directive
la commission fait une proposition et
appelons l'adisq et ensuite on a discuté
au parlement et au conseil des ministres
et donc là personnellement j'essaierais
de voir je n'ai pas encore étudié de
près le texte qui est sorti hier
comment on peut combiner les espaces de
transparence absolument nécessaire et
d'un autre côté aussi la protection des
intérêts légitimes par exemple d'une
entreprise je sais pas automobile ou
dans le secteur de l'énergie par rapport
à des concurrents non européens qui eux
ne seraient pas astreints aux mêmes
contraintes
alors d'un côté l'europe prône plus de
transparence bancaire et fiscale et de
l'autre pourtant il ya un rapport qui
est déposée cette semaine sur le secret
des affaires protéger ce secret est ce
que ce n'est pas antinomique
non ce n'est pas antinomique c'est la
vie il faut trouver un équilibre entre
les deux si on a à l'évidence besoin de
protéger le savoir faire de nos pme
le savoir faire qui n'est parfois pas
brevetable vous avez des entreprises
dans lesquelles un certain nombre de
secrets de fabrication sont extrêmement
importants qui ont qualité j'ai donc pas
du tout illégitime de les protéger et
alain vs il ya là matière fiscale
stricto sensu sur laquelle il faut plus
de transparence
ouais j'ai été condamné voilà il faut
combiner les deux mais je vois pas en
quoi le fait de permettre à des espions
parce que c'est 5 de s'introduire dans
des entreprises pour voler des secrets
d'affaires des qualités de marque et
cetera serait en soi une bonne
transparence
alors il ya les esprits mais aussi les
lanceurs d'alert qui peuvent fournir des
informations précieuses on dit que cette
directive que ce texte ce texte pour
remettre en cause peut porter préjudice
aux lanceurs d'alert est ce que c'est
vrai ou pas du tout je crois qu'il ya eu
un décalage un petit peu dans le temps
ce texte n'a été discutée depuis
longtemps il ne fait peut-être pas toute
la place qu'il faudrait à la protection
des lanceurs d'alerté
mais rien n'empêche de prendre un autre
je suis assez favorable à ce qu'on
adopte le texte sur le secret d'affaires
que pour les entreprises encore une fois
cette protection légitime je dis bien de
nos pm de nos marques de nos secrets de
fabrication soit actée et peut-être que
dans le même temps on tire les leçons
parce que dans les deux cas du
luxembourg et du panama ce sont des
personnes qui ont livré des informations
à la presse
il faut encadrer peut être protégé
veillez à ce qu'ils aient pas des
règlements de comptes parce que vous
savez il ya des aspects très positifs
dans le fait de lancer des alertes
il ya aussi pour une personne qui
salariés d'une entreprise d'une certaine
manière la trahison de ses obligations
de réserve donc là aussi il ya un
équilibre à trouver personnellement je
suis favorable à ce qu'on crée un statut
à part
il ya un domaine dans lequel l'europe
dit avoir progressé celles échange
automatique d'informations entre
administrations fiscales est ce que
c'est le cas ce que vous avez des
informations
oui je crois qu'il faut quand même aussi
dire que c'est grâce aux américains au
départ et qui ont joué un rôle assez
c'est là qu'on voit comme le jeu global
est ambiguë pendant très très longtemps
un certain nombre d'états européens
étaient totalement hostile à l'échangé
d'informations il était totalement
favorable au secret bancaire et un
certain nombre d'individus qui sont
maintenant parmi ceux qui demandent le
plus la transparence était autrefois du
côté des ministres à dire non non pas du
tout c'est qu'il ya eu un vrai
changement la wii il ya eu un changement
encore une fois il faut pas s'en prendre
le mérite parce qu'il ya eu aussi des
forces externes qui ont été très
efficaces notamment américaines et on y
est ça a changé et je crois honnêtement
que la crise depuis 2008 aussi bien sur
les aspects fiscaux que sur les
comportements des banques a introduit de
véritables changements
est-ce qu'ils sont suffisants pour la
prochaine crise je n'en sais rien mais
on ne peut pas les griller on a raison
que l'europe avance au fil des crises d
affaires est ce que c'est le cas elles
vont réagir après après tout c est
pourquoi parce que si je vous dis demain
matin qu' il faut se doter d'un certain
nombre de règles européennes qu'il faut
mutualiser certains contrôles
la plupart des gens en france durant ces
des fédéralistes foulée député européen
sont pas raisonnables le nombre de fois
où on entend ça n'est pas réel de massa
est pas raisonnable
moi j'ai dit que si on n'anticipe pas ce
que nous devrions faire sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais c'est pareil sur
le contrôle externe des frontières par
exemple pendant des années on n'a pas
voulu voir le problème
donc si on le dit l avance on est un
européen fou on n'a pas compris les
choses et puis après on nous reproche de
réagir donc il ya je crois besoin d'une
prise de conscience en europe
qu'il faut que nous réfléchissions au
type de société dans lequel nous voulons
vivre et au degré d'intégration que nous
voulons avoir non pas à partir des
théories fumeuses des souverainistes à
partir de la réalité du monde
message bien compris à l'intérieur du
citoyen européen merci beaucoup s'ils
voulaient arrêter notre invité est place
tout de suite à la deuxième partie
d'europe hebdo c'est l'itinéraire
principal de la majorité des migrants
venus d'irak de syrie ou d'afghanistan
la route des balkans elle est pourtant
devenue une voie dangereuse pour des
milliers d'entre eux d'autant que
plusieurs états situés sur la route
notamment la serbie ou la slovénie ont
décidé de fermer leurs frontières
résultat des centaines de migrants se
retrouvent bloqués notamment dans le
camp de tabac noche reportage sur place
de stéphanie des pierres regarder
nous
au nord de la macédoine à la frontière
avec la serbie
le camp de tabac noche des afghans des
syriens des irakiens plus d'un millier
de réfugiés s'entassent dc depuis début
mars faute de pouvoir continuer leur
route vers le nord et l'europe
occidentale
ils manquent de tout la situation est
mauvaise car la frontière est totalement
fermé il n'y a pas assez de nourriture
pour tous n'ont pas d'eau
j'ai perdu tous mes avoirs j'espérais
pouvoir aller dans un autre pays pour me
sauver moi et ma famille mais un peu
mieux que je peux pas retenir la croix
rouge locale distribuer des vivres
mais les quantités sont insuffisantes
les ong étrangères ne peuvent pas
intervenir autant qu'elle le
souhaiterait le camp de tabac noche
existe depuis plusieurs mois mais ce
n'était qu'un point de passage les
réfugiés s'arrêter ici quelques heures
pour se reposer avant de continuer vers
la serbie et le nord on passe en fait
d'un camp qui était un camp de transit à
un camp permanent qui n'était pas du
tout adaptée adapté à ce type de
population ce qui fait qu du coup au
niveau des équipements pour pouvoir
dormir pour pouvoir avoir accès à l'eau
avoir accès au pool eps avoir accès à
une hygiène corporelle acceptable on est
très en dessous des
des des capacités des normes
internationales désormais les réfugiés
sont deux fois trop nombreux pour la
taille du camp la situation sanitaire
est d'autant plus critique que la moitié
des habitants sont des enfants ça va
être de pire en pire si les gens restent
ici commence à faire chaud la chaleur va
aggraver les problèmes de santé si les
gens ne peuvent pas avoir accès un
minimum d'hygiène
il y a déjà des adultes qui sont ainsi à
l'hôpital et aussi des enfants quand les
réfugiés les enfants arrivent ici ils
ont voyagé des semaines voire des mois
ils sont déjà très vulnérable
physiquement et psychologiquement ce
jour là l'ambassadrice de france en
macédoine est venu sur place dans le
camp de tabac noche spontanément les
réfugiés viennent lui raconter leur
parcours et leur désespoir
nous ne pouvons pas rentrer dans notre
pays c'est la guerre nos maisons sont
détruites depuis deux ans
l'ambassadrice a l'air te parie sur les
risques d'une crise humanitaire en
macédoine
une situation qui s'est aggravée depuis
la fermeture des frontières
le 8 mars dernier on est dans ce système
de vases communicants ou si l'autriche
l'allemagne la slovénie la croatie et la
serbie prennent les décisions par
exemple de ne plus accepter telle ou
telle catégorie de migrants
la méphédrone ne veut pas se retrouver
avec un
un stop influent d'individus qui ne
peuvent pas gérer
et pourtant c'est ce qui s'est passé le
piège s'est refermé comme la macédoine
ne fait pas partie de l'union européenne
aucun accord ne se préoccupe du sort de
ces migrants après des semaines de
voyage à travers le moyen-orient et la
méditerranée
ces familles sont dans une impasse la
fermeture totale des frontières est
dangereuse et tous les gens dans les
bras des passeurs les pousse à prendre
des chemins plus dangereux puis nous
pourrons solution légale personne ne
sait ce qu'ils vont devenir
ils nous demandent tous à nous les ong
ce qu'il doit faire quelle est la voie
légale
malheureusement nous n'avons pas de
réponse personne n'a de réponse
en fait personne ne parle de ce sont des
réfugiés la macédoine pays pauvres
voudrait renvoyer ces réfugiés en grèce
mais athènes n'en veulent pas et ici
personne ou presque ne veut rebrousser
chemin
fatma à quitter l'irak début février
avec comme seul objectif l'europe
occidentale pas la masse et le web
adolphe steg
je ne l'en pas rester assise ce n'est
pas le lieu dont j'ai rêvé quand j'ai
quitté mon pays j'ai fui la guerre
j'ai tout quitté je rêvais d'un endroit
sûr où je pourrais devenir médecin une
personne normale finir mes études à voir
des amis je ne veux pas rester ici
où voulez vous allez je veux aller en
allemagne l'allemagne
un rêve qui paraît chaque jour un peu
plus inaccessible la route des balkans
semble bel et bien fermé
et pour longtemps et retour sur ces
plateaux à strasbourg nous accueillons
philippe landaise président du groupe
des verts ale le bonjour à jour merci
d'être avec nous alors vous avez vu ce
reportage on a volontairement choisi de
s'intéresser à ces migrants qui sont en
fait aux marches de l'espace schengen
est donc apparemment personne ne veut
est-ce que vous même vous connaissiez
vous saviez qu'il y avait un camp comme
ça de transit devenu camps improvisés à
tabac nos chances que vous vous étiez au
courant du sort de ces gens là quand je
ne connaissais pas l'existence en
particulier du quart de tableau chez par
contre j'ai connaissance du fait que le
changement d'attitude de certains
gouvernements européens a bloqué sur la
route des balkans
des dizaines de milliers de réfugiés et
donc forcément il doit bien se trouver
quelque part ils sont donc éparpillés
sur tout tout le long de cette route qui
est à emprunter qui du jour au lendemain
c'est fermé donc la responsabilité de
cette situation revient d'abord à ses
dirigeants des pays qui sont sur cette
route des balkans
non on glisse je crois que la
responsabilité principale vient des
états de l'union européenne et je parle
bien d établir une union européenne au
pluriel
j'ai bien entendu l'ambassadrice de
france qui parle de l'allemagne par
l'autriche
comme si le pays qu'elle représentait
n'avoue n'étaient pas concernés par la
fermeture des centres et qu'on m'a
absolument choquant ce qui se passe
c'est que face à ceux qui sont des
réfugiés de guerre il faut jamais
l'oublier
j'ai dit si vous étiez en irak si vous
étiez en syrie si vous étiez en
afghanistan vous tenteriez vous-même moi
aussi de fuir des pays en guerre quels
que soient les risques encourus
quels que soient les risques encourus je
veux dire si vous êtes confronté à
l'état islamique si vous êtes confronté
aux bombes russes américaines ou que
sais-je encore si vous êtes confrontés
au terrorisme au racket au crime
organisé au narco terroristes enfin aux
narcotrafiquants en en afghanistan ben
je pense que vous n'avez pas envie de
rester vivre la même quel que soit votre
attachement à ce pays l'allemagne a pris
la mesure du défi il y a un en disant
voilà nous voulons en fait assumer leurs
responsabilités et accueillir des
réfugiés mélamingue s'est très vite
retrouvée seule à part la suède
l'autriche qui l'ont suivi qui lui ont
emboîté le pas un temps les autres états
les autres états de l'union européenne
se sont tenues dans une réserve à la
fois je crois coupable et pas très
discrète et la france au premier rang
d'entre eux je rappelle quand même que
la france est la deuxième puissance
économique de l'union
c'est un pays qui prétend souvent co
diriger l'europe avec l'allemagne
or là dessus le silence de la france a
été assourdissant
quand il n'a pas été rompu par des
expressions de manuel valls à munich se
moquant presque de la chancelier alors
que la france en tout et pour tout s'est
engagé s'est engagé à accueillir trente
mille réfugiés en deux ans ce qui est à
peu près ce qui arrivait en allemagne au
pic de la delà de la vague en deux jours
et donc franchement l'attitude des
autres pays de l'union européenne est
gravissime
et si au contraire la france et
l'allemagne suivie j'en suis sûr par le
benelux par espagne par l'italie par
tant d'autres pays s'étaient mis
d'accord pour accueillir notre juste
part de réfugiés nous n'aurions pas
cette situation humanitaire que nous
observons maintenant dans les balkans
alors justement pour revenir un sondage
qu'on a vu la macédoine renvoie ces
migrants la grèce qui elle même n'en
veut pas du coup personne ne s'en occupe
est ce que l'europe peut faire quelque
chose mais évidemment grand évidemment
un gorille et le revenu personnel type 2
en afghanistan n'a rien vu son pardon en
macédoine ou en créer ou rendez bien
compte que sont pas quand même les pays
les plus riches de l'europe et la
macédoine en même temps de l'argent pour
une année ça veut dire qu'un pays comme
la belgique un pays comme la france
qu'un pays comme comme les pays-bas gras
pays comme l'espagne ne seront pas
capables d'accueillir non pas quelques
milliers mais quelques dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés c'est quand même
insensé ce que au bout de ce que vous
venez de dire sur la situation ces
réfugiés qui fuient des zones de guerre
on est que ce soit même en en irak en
syrie mais aussi en afghanistan est ce
que vous vous avez honte aujourd'hui de
l'attitude des pays de que vous êtes
cité dont la belgique absolument
absolument la belgique a accueilli un
temps dans les premiers jours de la
vague la belgique accueillis alors
c'était 200 personnes patchou on a
accueilli quelques milliers ce qui était
mieux que rien mais en tout cas on a
essayé de le faire mais quand la france
à fermer le camp de calais manu militari
qu'est ce qu'on a observé on a observé
une belgique
terrorisée à l'idée que peut-être
peut-être 2000 ou 2500 ha demandeurs
d'asile traverse la france la frontière
franco-belge pour aller vers le port de
zeebrugge et donc on a vu la belgique
fermé sa frontière avec la france en
fait qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays de
11 millions d'habitants a un revenu par
habitant est quand même très élevé qui
se sent incapable d'accueillir chez vu
dans des conditions décentes
quelques milliers de réfugiés je note
que c'est indigne un homme c'est
vraiment pas mon europe non vous êtes
inquiet je suis extrêmement inquiet
parce que ça qu'on assiste c'est
l'affirmation de plus en plus
décomplexée des égoïsmes nationaux des
égoïsmes même individuelle parce que de
nouveaux nous sommes dans des pays
riches mais dans des pays riches où la
richesse est quand même très injustement
partager dire si on observe les nuits
debout aujourd'hui c'est aussi une
insurrection par rapport à ça et je
pense que on observe même à l'intérieur
de nos sociétés ceux qui sont les mieux
lotis finalement se dit eh bien tant pis
pour les autres
alors non seulement l'europe n'accueille
pas comme vous le dites mais on observe
aussi des réactions de rejet dans
certains pays il ya eu notamment ces
photos qui ont circulé sur le web de
violence dans le candide only en grèce
vous les avez vu ces photos sont très
choquantes
voilà est-ce que quand vous voyez sa
violence aussi dans certains pays en
bulgarie où des milices ont ligoté des
idées migrants on parle même aussi de
certains incidents en allemagne quand
vous voyez des centaines d'incidents
anti anti migrants c'est c'est très
clair donc que son film est comme ça à
la dérobée quand vous voyez ça vous vous
dites quoi
eh bien je me dis l'europe est en train
de retomber dans des scènes que qui nous
rappelle quand même les années 30 et je
pense que se dire qu'en europe nous
sommes à jamais vacciner contre ce genre
de choses et bien je pense que c'est une
très grosse erreur
l'europe s'est construite après la
deuxième guerre mondiale sur un projet
qui visait la paix par l'extension de la
démocratie et par le partage de la
prospérité
autrement dit c'est à la fois la
question de la démocratie de la justice
sociale et on voit que ces piliers
essentiels essentielle de l'intégration
européenne sont en train de s'effriter
sous les coups de boutoir à la fois je
vais dire de groupes radicaliser de
notamment de la droite radicale mais
aussi d'une partie significative de la
classe politique qui aujourd'hui n'a
plus l'audace de se battre pour une
société plus juste plus démocratique et
au 21ème siècle plus durable
c'est vraiment de ça qu'il s'agit
et le retour du chacun pour soi à la fin
c'est la violence un jour mis tellement
a dit le nationalisme c'est la guerre
mais je dirais que l'individualisme
c'est la violence c'est la violence
l'europe incapable de régler cette crise
qui l'a qui la dépasse finalement son
derby à la turquie ya un mois il ya eu
un accord signé avec la turquie pour
renvoyer les réfugiés vers la turquie
alors c'est l'accord dit un pour un un
réfugié renvoyé en turquie pour un
accueilli en europe
est-ce que vous avez un premier bilan de
cet accord est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura bien fait de 6,17 à colabor sept
accords et est illégal au sens les
conventions que nous avons aussi bien la
convention de genève qui nous oblige
d'accueillir les demandeurs d'asile
d'autres elle est traitée
individuellement et nous ne pouvons pas
les renvoyer
individuellement ou collectivement c'est
ce que dit à convaincre je leur ai donc
on fait semblant on fait semblant que la
turquie est un pays sûr pour vous à dire
à ben ils sont d'abord arrivés en
turquie donc on peut les renvoyer en
turquie tout en sachant que la turquie
n'applique pas la convention de genève à
la limite elle a un traitement un peu
particulier pour les syriens mais on
apprend aujourd'hui que la turquie
renverrait sous réserve d'une enquête
des syriens ont dans leur pays en guerre
parmi ces ce n'est quand même des kurdes
bien sûr c'est évidemment est tellement
on connaît bien et tout le monde connaît
bien le problème grave des kurdes et des
kurdes de turquie met donc on sait très
bien que le président erdogan pour
gagner une élection a relancé la guerre
civile contre sa population kurde à
leurs lois de moi de dire que le pkk qui
défend les ceintures c'est une bande
d'enfants de choeur certainement pas
manger quand on voit les actes de
violences qu'ils commettent ce sont des
choses inacceptables néanmoins
l'initiative de la rupture des
négociations entre les tailles pkk elle
revient au gouvernement erdogan qui
ensuite a relancé la violence pour
pouvoir gagner une élection ce avec ce
type là qu'ont dit les quand vous dites
c'est l'incapacité des européens c'est
pas la capacité des européens c'est
l'absence de volonté des européens parce
que la capacité nous l'avons nous
n'avons eu et n'avons pas la volonté
politique accueillir accueillir même
pour pour citer un chiffre que certains
trouveront texte m
un million de réfugiés par an meurent
pendant cinq ans ça veut dire 5 millions
de réfugiés 5 millions de réfugiés c'est
1% la population européenne
ne me dites pas que l'europe n'est pas
capable de faire ça donc c'est qu'elle
ne le veut pas
donc c'est possible pour vous merci
beaucoup ce sera le mot de la fin
merci philippe lambert soir était notre
invité de cette émission on se quitte
et je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine cette fois à bruxelles avec
nora hamadi très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
merci de votre fidélité